[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to you Destiny rack 60 millimeter film
print
this film print is the fine-tuned power
grade which can be used on both regular
footage like Rec 709 or log footage
which can be either 10 bit or even 8-bit
most film prints are not fighting for a
bit and will make your colors fall apart
but when I create my grades I keep in
mind that most people have 8-bit cameras
and to be honest here I don't always
want to shoot 10 bit either because it
takes up more space so I just make the
grade suitable for 8-bit cameras as well
in the studio for example we should raw
or at least 10 bit color files but that
is because we're working on Proto
commercials and we need the most
information that we can get but for
YouTube everything I create is a bit and
that is more than enough if you ask me
so don't feel limited by your camera
it's all about the techniques that
you're using so the cine Rec 16 is a
very fine-tuned power grade to prevent
colors falling apart even on more
consumer cameras which can only record
8-bit footage of course the more
information the better rendition of
color you will get so using it on higher
end cameras that can shoot 10-bit color
or raw footage will end up in much nicer
tones and color transitions I've tested
the cine Rec 16 millimeter power grade
on the new aerial Lexa 35 and it looks
great I compared 4 different cameras and
you can check out that comparison on my
channel
this film pack includes 11 different
base presets for daytime and nighttime
conditions and all of them are fully
customizable for your own personal style
oh by the way this video was shot on the
new Sony classic Chrome film simulation
which is a high fidelity copy of the
Fujifilm simulation based only on Sony
picture profile menu
which means you can get Fuji colors on
Sony cameras Straight Out of the Box
also have a video presentation on that
link in the upright corner so if you're
interested in Sony film simulations you
can find all 26 recipes on my website
link down below generally speaking I try
to keep my power grades very neat and
tidy I want everything to be very easy
to find and understand and that is
because sometimes less is more and as
you can see the cine Rec 16 millimeter
is not an exception everything is named
accordingly so you can identify each
effect much easier and if you hover over
a node you can see exactly what
adjustments have been made and where
also in the product folder I included a
note sheet where I explained the effect
of each node and in which menu can find
the settings to further adjust it if
needed
as you can see every effect is separated
and it's making the searching process
much much easier
you can select multiple nodes and
deactivate them if you don't need that
effect or would like to see how it looks
without those adjustments
so basically you have noise reduction
temperature contrast and saturation
nodes which all seem very
straightforward to me as I mentioned
before if you hover over a specific node
you can see exactly where the
adjustments have been made next you have
film color which is the main color
grading node
film damage adds different Hues in the
shadows and highlights for a more
artistic color grade
dsat low high will give you more control
by decreasing the intensity of colors in
the shadows and the highlights for more
subtle and professional looking great
you also have D sharp to increase detail
softness which helps us very much with
the skin tones and losing that digital
Edge
this node will also give you a very
subtle glow which is very nice lastly we
have the vignetting the halation and
green effect
I have a video tutorial on halation
effects you can check it out in the
upright corner or later
the bar grid is super easy to use and
adjust everything being fully
customizable to import it all you have
to do is create a power grade album by
going in the left corner where it says
Gallery right click and choose create
new power grid album double click to
rename it as cinerex 16 millimeter fill
print then right click and import only
the DPX files
foreign
from there choose any desired clip and
either drag it on top of an empty node
or right click on the power grid and
select add to current node
you can use it as it is on rack 709 or
lock footage lock footage might need
some color correction because of the
wider color gamut which usually has more
of the green tones if you are an
experienced colorist you can do this
manually or you can add a color space
transform and convert your log footage
into Rec 709 color space to ensure
colors are where they're supposed to be
you can also use the official camera log
to rec 709 conversion Lots which can be
found on each camera brand official
website
[Music]
afterwards adjust contrast and
saturation on your own liking and it's
pretty much good to go
after translating colors into Rec 709
you might need to lower the saturation
and decrease the contrast to balance out
the image
for the contrast node remember to
activate the spline and unlink the Luma
from the RGB values doing so it will
only affect the Luma without influencing
the saturation of different color
channels while increasing the contrast
and from here it's pretty much good to
go unless you want to go inside each
node and check what I've done and maybe
push things even further
in the case you're working in different
color spaces than Rec 709 color
separation might happen due to the
different shapes of the color space
but first just try to disable and enable
deflation effect and if that is creating
the color separation then just lift the
threshold until it disappears maybe too
much of the image is being affected by
the halation node
if this is not solving the issue then
let's get into the film color node every
color space has a different shape and
different dominant colors for example P3
DCI which is used for Cinema has a
predominance in the blue tones while a
white gamut will have a tendency towards
the green Hues so by using the color
space transform you can translate your
footage into different color spaces and
that will require subtle adjustments to
the power braid no worries it's nothing
difficult and I'll show you exactly how
most problems happen between the yellow
to Green transition or the blue pink
colors generally speaking I would say
these are the ugliest colors if I can
label them as that maybe it's a harsh
label or at least the most problematic
from the whole visible spectrum
it's very easy to get these colors to
look unattractive so many companies
choose to shift them or to saturate them
to render better colors
for example most Canon cameras I've
created so far have this tendency to
desaturate yellow and magenta pretty
heavily which is the perfect recipe for
pleasing skin tones
natural skin tones are not always the
most attractive looking and that is
because they have a lot of green yellow
magenta tones hot pinks and micro flaws
so just by working with these colors you
can actually get perfect skin tones very
easily next time you color gray skin
tones remember these details and you
will notice a huge Improvement in skin
color rendition just by doing a couple
simple steps interesting fact yellow
magenta don't even exist or at least our
eyes gonna see them because our eyes can
only capture shades of red green and
blue
so yellow magenta are actually brain
generated I guess to fill in the space
between the main colors that we see
which is pretty cool if you think about
it but these are the colors that will
give us most problems in color grading
and we might not even know it so if
you're having some color separation
between these colors I'll show you
exactly what to do and don't worry it's
very simple all you have to do go into
the Hue versus Hue menu and shift the
yellow green nodes decreasing the
contrast between them and also give them
some more space until the color
separation disappears
do the same thing with the blue magenta
nodes until there is no more color
separations and that should solve it
[Music]
you can also adjust the formulation
effects and green power on your personal
taste
one thing that you might have to
recalibrate is the green shifter node
this is a very special node made to very
finely select the greens present in the
darker part of the scene and shift them
towards cyan this will add Dimension and
interest to your color since the
brightest greens will be yellow while
the darker parts will be shifted
dramatically towards cyan this is
exactly how many analog film stocks
would render color and it's a nice
addition to the power grade making your
footage look closer to real film to edit
this node go into the cooler fire window
and start selecting the area that you
like to be shifted towards a Kohler
deeper green
foreign
to see exactly the area which is
affected by this node and finally adjust
the range by either reducing or
expanding the area of effect
maybe soften it as well as reduce harsh
transitions from one color to another
increase the blurry radius as good to go
you can change the desired shifting
color by going into the primaries and
drag the mid tone wheel towards your
desired area
as you can see it looks very natural
with very nice transitions between the
Shadows to highlight
if you notice the Revelation is very
subtle and natural I played a lot with
the settings to come to this recipe but
you can still go inside and play even
more if you want something more
pronounced or maybe even slightly subtle
you can find these power grades on my
website link down below or if you want
to learn how to manually grade from
scratch you can book a color grading
session with me it's a private course
where I'll help you understand color
grading in a much easier way and how to
achieve any kind of look faster
you can find the link to the course in
the description down below and in my
next video I'll be showing even more
sample footage created with the cine
rack 60 millimeter from my trip to
Bucharest doing street photography it
was a super exciting trip and I also
show you some Sony film simulation
samples straight out of camera so till
next time take care and remember have
fun see ya
foreign
[Music]